bonjour bienvenue à tous et parlement
hebdo 45 minutes de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire avec aude
moracchini vos joueurs de jean michaël
bonjour à tous et on commence évidemment
par l'information principale de cette
semaine c'est bien sûr la culture de
dominique strauss kahn aux états unis il
est accusé de tentative d'agression
sexuelle et de viol sur une femme de
chambre d'un hôtel de new york
renault était déféré devant un tribunal
il a finalement été libéré sous caution
les images ont fait le tour du monde
dsk a dû également démissionné de son
poste de directeur général du fmi
un coup de tonnerre ce sont les mots de
martine aubry longue de choc a atteint
l'ensemble du parti socialiste rue de
solferino c'est toute la stratégie des
primaires qui est à revoir
réunion en urgence du bureau national et
martine aubry qui devait s'effacer
derrière une candidature dsk va devoir
monter au front enfin on parlera cinéma
le film la conquête qui retrace
l'ascension au pouvoir de nicolas
sarkozy
projeté sur la croisette lors du
festival de cannes mais aussi dans
toutes les salles de france vous êtes
toutes les réactions des parlementaires
est avec nous pour commenter l'actualité
robert hue bonjour merci d'être avec
nous sur ce plateau vous êtes sénateur
du val-d'oise président d'une formation
que vous avez fondé un an après avoir
quitté le parti communiste le muc fond
écru mp3 encore j'ai pas voulu la faire
le muc c'est le mouvement unitaire
progressiste donc qui revendique
quelques centaines d'adhérents et quatre
conseillers régionaux depuis l'année
dernière
deux parlementaires vis là vous
autorisez la double adhésion celui du
parti communiste et en même temps vous
dites est dur et stylistes et du pass
tennis que vous êtes à mille lieues du
parti communiste aujourd'hui aux
élections régionales l'année dernière
certaines vos candidats au même figurer
sur les listes du parti socialiste
alors aujourd'hui de kent famille vous
vous sentez le plus proche du parti
socialiste de martine aubry de jean luc
mélenchon de la famille des
progressistes c'est à dire que moi je
suis issu de la famille communiste
même si je ne suis plus dans l'appareil
et j'ai quitté le parti communiste pour
des raisons qui tiennent à sa structure
aujourd'hui alors je lui dirigé pendant
dix ans mais je reste avec ma
sensibilité communiste
je ne suis je me retrouve pas dans la
stratégie du front de gauche plus que
jamais aujourd'hui parce que je
considère qu' il faut unir la gauche dès
le premier tour plutôt que de diviser la
gauche et et qu'une famille politique de
gauche tape sur l'autre famille
politique pour faire en fait commerce
électoral
donc je ne je ne m'inscris pas dans une
démarche comme ça mais je ne suis pas
non plus décidé de me situer en
assujettis d'un parti socialiste qui qui
garde des tendances hégémoniques très
fort entre deux rives si on peut dire en
tous les cas je veux fédérer ceux qui ne
se retrouvent ni dans une démarche de
front de gauche tous elle est
respectable mais mehenni dans une
démarche totalement socialos aussi la
rue on va y revenir sur l'échéance 2012
bien sûr mais évidemment on va commencer
avec le choc de la semaine dsk arrêté
pour agression sexuelle
lundi la france découvre sidéré les
images de dominique strauss kahn sortant
du commissariat où il a passé la nuit
menottes au poignet on le retrouve un
peu plus tard filmé au tribunal où il
apprend son incarcération dans l'une des
prisons les plus dures du pays des
images déjà gravé dans la mémoire
collective et que nous commente marion
lefebvre menotté dans le dos encadré par
deux enquêteurs de la police new
yorkaise
dominique strauss kahn quitte le
commissariat de harlem
visiblement fatigué et crispé et des
images chocs et les premières depuis
l'arrestation du directeur du fonds
monétaire international il est 23h
samedi 16 mai dominique strauss kahn
vient de passer trente heures en garde à
vue
accusé d'acte sexuel criminel tentative
de viol et séquestration
quelques heures plus tard le patron du
fmi est emmené au dépôt du tribunal
new york sous l'oeil des caméras du
monde entier
c'est ici qu'il attend son audience
dominique strauss kahn patiente sur un
banc avant lui d affaires de petite
délinquance sont traités fut l'audience
débute l'accusation prend la parole et
détaille les faits qui lui sont
reprochés
elles demandent son maintien en
détention puis c'est au tour de la
défense pendant de longues minutes
l'avocat de dominique strauss kahn
défend la liberté sous caution de son
client
j'entends vos arguments mais votre
client était sur le point d'embarquer
dans un avion c'est ça qui me pose
problème
les risques de fuite vers la france sont
trop grands la juge refuse la remise en
liberté sous caution dominique strauss
kahn est aussitôt incarcéré à la prison
de rikers island
c'est là qu'il attend son audition
devant le grand jury vendredi elle les
jurés populaires se prononceront sur
l'inculpation formelle de dominique
strauss kahn
les sept chefs d'accusation énoncés par
la justice américaine sont passibles
d'une peine de prison au total de 74 ans
alors ça c'était donc la journée de
lundi le jeu d'il ya une autre audience
devant un autre juge cette fois
dominique strauss kahn a été remis en
liberté très surveillée
en même temps il a été officiellement
inculpé ce qui veut dire qu'il y aura
normalement procès est ce que vous êtes
robert russes satisfaits du
fonctionnement de la justice américaine
écoutez c'est une c'est une réalité
on ne peut pas la contourner puisque
c'est est encore un choix de deux il
reste que mon humainement
naturellement je suis comme beaucoup de
français qui ont vécu cette s'il vient
de se passer comme une sorte de 2,2 de
tragédie où la réalité dépasse la
fiction
dans bien des domaines avec une onde de
choc un malaise terrible est que au lieu
de ce bail moderne dans lequel ils
étaient 2000 strauss kahn se retrouve
dans une situation différente du point
de vue de sang
en liberté surveillée mais dans les
conditions nouvelles très strictes
d'ailleurs mais je me sens en
fonctionnement normal de la justice
américaine c'est toujours comme ça et je
pense même mois que la première partie
celle que vous avez montré d'ailleurs où
on voit qu'il ya une véritable mise en
scène les images de dominique strauss
kahn à dessein son sont mises en
situation et est un choix de la justice
américaine est un choix qui lui peut
apparaître un délit mais je voudrais
dire quand même que tout ça entraîne
dans la tête des français
une des choses qui se qui se télescopent
il y a cet homme puissant qui descend
aux enfers
il y à une sorte de comment dirais-je il
y avait des certitudes qui se
construisait autour d'une alternance
avec lui si ce n'est une alternative
mais en tous les cas et est tous assez
font pas seulement d'ailleurs pour la
gauche et je pense qu'il faut faire bien
attention ce n'est pas la gauche
seulement qui a été marqué par ces
événements et donc je considère qu'il y
à la mémé ce que je veux dire quand même
c'est il ya une telle il ya un tel
malaise à une telle réaction de
l'opinion publique voire des dénis de la
gauche que e.on on voit bien que dans la
toute première partie on oublie qu'il ya
une femme qui a une femme dans cette
affaire et qu'elle allait la justice
américaine dit qu'elle a été victime
d'un viol donc je crois que il y à là à
chercher l'équilibré alors nous sommes
dans une situation où en fait il ya une
certaine fragilisation liés à ce que
sont les hommes providentiels dans les
situations et dans les circonstances
lorsqu'ils sont touchés
c'est tout le système qui est touchée
reverrai qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
des images de dominique strauss kahn
avec les menottes aux poignets ou son
arrivée comme on le voit sur ces images
devant le tribunal qu'est ce que vous
pensez de saisie mais je pense que c'est
bien sûr une cruauté absolue que je
pense que la justice américaine pouvait
gagner dans une procédure qui n'appelle
pas une telle mise en scène
ça retire rien à la gravité des faits
présumés
parce que je il faut trouver l'équilibré
nécessaire ça n'est pas réservé à
dominique strauss kahn on sait que les
américains mais michel gonzalez et où
les délinquants
vous avez raison peut-être moi je ne
suis pas tous les procès américains
comme j'ai été attentif à ce qui s'est
passé à ce qui s'est passé là ce que je
sais c'est que il s'est ressentie par
des gens qui ne sont pas quand même
neutre je suis moi quelqu'un qui
connaissait dominique strauss kahn qui
connaît dominique strauss kahn et qui en
fait un regard sur lui qui n'est pas
seulement celui du de la tragédie qui se
vit et du crime qui peut-être at-il
commis ce qui n'est pas démontrée mais
en même temps il cette femme est doit
être victime présumée entendu et
regardez je trouve qu'on a eu là une
faiblesse dans le cognaçais dominique
strauss kahn est ce que vous vous êtes
dit comme ça en première réaction comme
certains membres de son entourage c'est
impossible ce n'est pas un homme violent
bon moi je n'ai je ne peux pas dire que
c'est un homme violent je n'ai jamais vu
je ne suis pas je ne connais pas et
personnalités oui je connaissais
personnalité vous savez je suis sénateur
du val-d'oise
il essaie son département avec dominique
strauss kahn nous avons travaillé dans
les périodes de la gauche plurielle
beaucoup non c'est je ne peux pas je
n'imaginais pas que où je n'imagine pas
qu'il puisse effectivement avoir de tels
comportements violents mais aujourd'hui
que d'autres apportent des témoignages
que moi je n'ai pas vécu ou connu
je vois que des choses sont dites il y
pourrait y faire imaginer des pulsions
agressives mais bon c'est je ne porte
pas de jugement là dessus et assez de
choses de dites alors comment ont réagi
les parlementaires à cette affaire sous
le choc aussi à l'assemblée tout d'abord
consignes de discrétion à la réunion de
groupe ump du mardi matin et quelques
langues se délient l'après-midi gerny
hartmann en arrivant ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale les ministres ont
appliqué à la lettre le mot d'ordre
donné par nicolas sarkozy lors du petit
déjeuner de la majorité
la sphère strauss kahn doit être abordée
avec dignité sang froid
dans l'hémicycle cet après midi
l'incarcération du directeur du fmi n'a
pas été évoquée pendant les questions au
gouvernement devant les journalistes en
revanche les langues de certains députés
ump
ce délit ou loire à tout prix victimiser
monsieur strauss kahn c'est quand même
oublier une jeune femme qui a été
agressée on a connu de meilleurs combats
de la part du parti socialiste pour
défendre justement les femmes agressées
par la violence sexuelle des hommes le
lecteur moyen et se dit m'attendais
c'est pour des gens comme ça que je vote
c'est vraiment ces gens là qui nous
dirigent des attaques pour certains de
la retenue pour d'autres à plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres de new york
c'est d'abord l'incertitude qui domine
et chez les socialistes la frustration
de ne pas en savoir plus on s'est offert
nous savons qu'il y à une victime mais
nous ne savons pas encore si cette
victime et la plaignante ou l'accusé
aucun événement de ces dernières n'a
permis à dominique strauss kahn de
s'exprimer et je crois que l'ensemble de
nos concitoyens avaient besoin
d'entendre sa vérité faute de pouvoir
parler du fond les députés se penchent
davantage sur la forme de cette affaire
très médiatique dans les films
américains par les films de fiction on
avait déjà eu vu ce genre de voeux
d'image mais là c'est autre chose c'est
la réalité une justice spectacle qui
pour les élus de la nation ne doit pas
ternir l'image de la politique française
dans son ensemble
réactions à présent du groupe du parti
socialiste au sénat vous allez longtemps
des propos contrastent est recueilli par
sandra cerqueira
et c'est vrai que
on a on a pensé que la dimension de cet
homme portait une espérance pour ce pays
- voilà
comment comment gérer le jour d'après
même sur la main je pense pas tous les
faits qui lui sont reprochés sont réels
maintenant il faut laisser la justice
suit son cours ça sera majoré ou nantes
si bien évidemment la justice inculpé
dominique strauss kahn monsieur strauss
kahn n'est pas le seul homme au sein de
la gauche c'est un parmi d'autres
voilà d'ailleurs il était même pas
candidat aux primaires donc voila fr la
continuer robert hue il ya des réactions
des politiques qui vous ont choqué
notamment celle de jean pierre
chevènement par exemple qui a dit que
c'est comme ça qu'a commencé l'affairé
dreyfus ça vous a choqué successifs à
mon avis c'est une comparaison qui est à
prendre
hamon avec plus de recul non moi je je
je comprends le ce que je viens de voir
avec vous là deux des réactions mais
mais je pense qu'il faut que les hommes
politiques les femmes politiques de ce
pays ait le courage de regarder quelque
chose auquel on est confronté en tout
état de cause c'est la fragilité d'un
système qui repose sur souvent une
personnalisation excessive d'ailleurs ce
soit au pouvoir ou dans l'opposition et
un système qui conduit à ce que lorsque
l'homme ou la femme providentiel ne sont
plus en situation
c'est l'effondrement ça c'est pas
possible on ne fait pas fonctionner une
démocratie avec eux et je ça rejoint
leur le problème que j'ai
personnellement avec les institutions je
pense que la personnalisation liées à
l'élection du président de la république
au suffrage universel que les français
considèrent comme un choix démocratique
mais moi je pense qu'elle est à la ses
perversions et qu'elle conduit à se
construire une personnalité c'est
l'homme ou la femme qui son rapport
direct avec le pays tout cela
oui mais ça c'est c'est un culte du chef
peut-être que au moment où le général de
gaulle a imaginé ces institutions elle
correspondait en tous les cas son
personnage assurément et à une réalité
du moment
mais aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut une
évolution sensible
une première dans l'histoire de france
quel homme providentiel descendent
autant aux enfers email avant que la
force que ça peut exister
la prof que ça peut exister et je
suppose qu'il paye à d'autres situations
ou accidentels ou quelqu'un disparaît en
pleine faudrait revoir les conseillers
je suis fondamentalement pour que on
diminue la démarche on on limite la
démarche de personnalisation
présidentialiste dans les institutions
françaises et qu'on a une constitution
qui soit qui donne une nouvelle éthique
de la république ça nous sommes on
peut-être parlons nous de deux films qui
sortent actuellement la période des
missions que vous voulez vous créer
c'est des choses qui traduisent bien ce
qui est la personnalisation sa fragilité
et ses dangers lorsqu'elle est liée à la
vie personnelle est un seul homme une
seule femme
c'est dangereux a vécu dans la semaine
c'est amplifier une polémique elle est
venue des journalistes américains qui
s'étonne de l'omerta française autour
des moeurs du monde politique
en clair ils reprochent aux français de
ne pas avoir donné l' alerte sur les
penchants du patron du fmi
réponse sur une question complexe
aurélie marcireau face à l' affaire dsk
les relations entre journalistes et
politiques sont une nouvelle fois en
question la presse outre atlantique ne
comprend pas et dénonce canucks islands
une omerta en france un président un
enfant hors mariage personne n'en parle
un ministre des affaires étrangères a
une liaison avec la fille d'un ministre
syrien personne n'en parle
les journalistes français protège la vie
privée des dirigeants fille cachée de
françois mitterrand séparation de
françois hollande et ségolène royal
depuis toujours rien ne filtre sur le
comportement privé des politiques
notamment concernant leur rapport aux
femmes
tout le monde savait que dominique
strauss kahn aimait beaucoup les jolies
femmes de là à en faire un violeur
et de là à dire que tout le monde savait
qu'il pouvait commettre ce genre d'actes
il ya une marge que je ne franchis pas
jamais je n'ai entendu quoi que ce soit
sur la pathologie dont certains pâle
tout le monde savait mais ce avec quoi
dsk séducteur comme beaucoup d'autres
parfois pressants des rumeurs et
quelques zones d'ombré qui soit un
séducteur ça le regarde et moi
personnellement je vois pas pourquoi
j'aurais à enquêter sur le fait qu'ils
soient un séducteur ou pas après si
j'avais eu à connaître des faits
illégaux je pense que les journalistes
dans ce cas-là français comme les autres
en quête d'un comportement libertin à
une possible affaire pénale
l'enchaînement était difficilement
imaginable mais à quel moment les
journalistes devait-il sortir de leur
silence
il ne doit pas y avoir de silence cela
va de soi c'est à dire que si quelqu'un
est informée qu'une personne quelle
qu'elle soit qu'elles soient publiques
ou pas d'ailleurs commet un acte qui est
contraire à la loi
et bien cela doit se savoir et faire
l'objet naturellement d'une procédure
les médias français aujourd'hui
s'interroge si dominique strauss kahn
est jugé coupable
ils seront accusés d'avoir caché des
informations et la question d'une plus
grande transparence sera de nouveau posé
une question complexe 1 on ne sait plus
trop parfois trois on parle si on est
dans le harcèlement dans la séduction
jusqu'à l'agression à partir de quand
doit-on abandonné la règle de protection
de la vie privée
je crois que lorsqu'il ya manifestement
manif manifestement un quelque chose de
délictuelles il faut absolument prendre
sur soi de de dire de révéler mais mais
là c'est très complexe dans la situation
y compris dominique strauss kahn bon des
choses aujourd'hui se révèlent elles
n'ont pas fait l'objet de plaintes elles
n'ont pas autant d'éléments qui est
qu'il était difficile pour les
journalistes souvent montré du doigt de
jean françois kahn qui parlait de
troussage de domestique
oui c'est pas défendable mais bon il se
situe au-dessus d'un dérapage je pense
qu'il va en maîtriser
mérite mieux que cette la pression qu'on
pourrait porter sur des propos comme
ceux-là n'ont eu cesse qu'on est allé
trop loin
certains propos sont allés trop loin ou
pas bah écoutez en tous les cas certains
propos révèlent la difficulté la
contradiction dans laquelle on se trouve
il ya une vie privée est respectée à
partir de quel moment vous les
journalistes vous entrez dans la vie
privée est donc dépassé ce qui est
raisonnable mais en même temps votre
métier en france en tous les cas c'est
la conception en france et d'accompagner
les hommes et les femmes politiques
tout au long de leur démarche politique
donc vous êtes confrontés à des
situations où alors évidemment il faut
savoir quelle est la limite des choses
moi j'entends beaucoup de monde
aujourd'hui dire telle ou telle chose
concernant dominique strauss kahn en
même temps gens comme tout à l'heure
c'est vallini je crois qu'ils aient
évoqué sa dent dans l'interview
moi je n'ai entendu que des choses qui
étaient connus que c'était quelqu'un
effectivement qui était en permanence en
séduction etc mais mais de là à imaginer
ce que pourrait être le crime s'il est
avéré c'est gravissime le viol non ça
c'est donc c'est difficile mais je crois
que un certain nombre de vos confrères
avaient dit les choses 1 et on bon ils
n'ont pas pu le dire dans leurs journaux
ils l'ont dit sur leur blog sur y
compris dominique strauss kahn
aujourd'hui on voit bien que là il y à
cette affaire nous conduit à regarder
les choses différemment
nous ne sommes plus comme avant les
choses ont changé complètement on vers
une des conséquences évidemment c'est la
démission de dominique strauss kahn du
fmi a fait part de sa décision dans une
lettre adressée à l'institution c'est
avec une grande tristesse qui se sent
obligé de présenter sa démission
nous avons accompli ensemble de si
grandes choses ces dernières années
peut-on lire dans cette lettre
je vous propose de recueillir tout de
suite et d'écouter la réaction de
christine lagarde la ministre de
l'économie qui pourrait postuler à ce
poste laissé vacant
toute candidature quelle qu'elle soit
devra émaner des européens qui se
rassemblent tous ensemble
robert hue est ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui que christine lagarde
pourrait être une des représentantes du
fmi est ce que l'europe doit garder la
place au fmi la présidence ce que je
sais c'est qu'il y aura une différence
sensible
je pense entre ce qui avait tenté de
mettre en oeuvre avec beaucoup de
défauts dominique strauss kahn
une démarche keynésienne à bien des
égards l'idée de relance là une place
plus grande aux pays émergents et la
conduite de deux du fmi par madame
lagarde en plus à l'est c'est pas elle
est quand même porté par ce qu'il ya de
plus conservateur et libéral en europe
c'est donc à l'aide d'un feu des à
nicolas sarkozy madame merkel la pousse
berlusconi hier ça m'inspire pas
beaucoup de joie il faut bien dire que
je verrai pas d'un bon oeil cette
présidence j'ai fait mais je n'ai pas
d'illusions non plus sur cette structure
aujourd'hui il faut continuer les
réformes plus avec plus de rupture
encore que l'avait imaginé données
sociales kahn à la tête du fmi
le bilan oui bah c'est un bilan en
équilibre
l'institution est claire elle ne me
convient pas elle elle s'inscrit dans
une démarche qui est davantage encore de
2,2 de faire payer un certain nombre de
nos peuples d'austérité de difficultés
il reste que dominique strauss kahn a
géré en bon sociale-démocrate s'est
avéré positif
je n'ai pas je ne porte pas un jugement
pauzé jeu je porte un jugement nuancé
avec des aspects positifs et d'autres
aspects très négatif lié à la structure
liée à la situation dans laquelle se
trouve l'économie mondiale mais mais il
ya une relance keynésienne une
adaptation ou logiques financières
libéral en même temps vous voyez c'est
très nuancée et aux verts et jean-luc
mélenchon avait dit de dominique strauss
kahn que c'était la faveur des peuples
en parle notamment des conséquences sur
la grèce vous partager son avis non mais
je ne ne partagent pas les formules de
jean luc mélenchon c'est ce qui me fait
est en opposition singulière avec la
stratégie du front de gauche
si on pense qu'en en assassinant les
gens comme ça par des formules
allez les gars v pour certains et si on
va on c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait de
la politique
à mon avis moi je combattais un certain
nombre de thèses social-démocrate vous
social libéral de dominique strauss kahn
mais bon la faveur des peuples etc
ça c'est un travail mais je n'ai pas ma
façon de faire moi je suis pour une
démarche constructive
ça c'est de la destruction sas a pondu à
l'échec de la gauche robert hue on va
passer au mardi quand le parti
socialiste réunit son bureau national
toujours sous le choc que martine aubry
a rassemblé ses troupes rue de solférino
l'heure est à l'unité du parti
socialiste at-elle affirmé la sphère
strauss kahn est dans toutes les têtes
mais la première secrétaire a voulu
montrer que le parti est toujours au
travail les primaires approche et la
donne a changé et liv aicardi nationale
n'a pas duré plus de 45 minutes à la
sortie martine aubry lance un appel
résumer en trois mots unité
responsabilité combativité
encore sous le choc la première
secrétaire ne veut pas oublier
l'essentiel pour le parti les prochaines
échéances il y à l'émotion bien sûr il
ya le bouleversement que chacun ressent
mais il ya notre responsabilité être à
la hauteur et je le dis très simplement
aux français nous serons au rendez-vous
de 2012 le parti socialiste sera là
pressé par ses proches martine aubry ne
veut pas bousculer son calendrier pour
autant l'idée de sa candidature pourtant
semble à présent faire son chemin et
s'imposer chez certains dirigeants
martin aujourd'hui nous à rassembler a
dit les mots qu'il fallait nous l'avons
accompagné plusieurs se sont exprimés
pour accompagner cet état d'esprit et
effectivement elle elle représente
aujourd'hui notre rassemblement et même
d'une certaine manière à potentiel de
rassemblement de la gauche
elle est le point de stabilité
aujourd'hui
clairement le le référent dans un moment
tous confrontés situation exceptionnelle
en attendant les choix de martine aubry
les candidats déjà déclarés font bloc et
joue l'unité avec un message fort tout
de même la sphère strauss kahn ne doit
pas entacher le parti socialiste et leur
avenir
nous sommes très nombreux à ne pas
accepter que cette affaire soit utilisé
contre nous tous le projet socialiste
sera votée vendredi par les militants
l'occasion pour martine aubry et les
autres de tester le message du jour
l'unité robert hue aujourd'hui par
exemple jean paul huchon a déclaré qu'il
fallait ouvrir les primaires qu'il
fallait arrêter le processus des
primaires et les ouvrir peut-être à la
gauche de la gauche voire aux
écologistes vous êtes d'accord avec ça
j'imagine m'écouter en tous les cas je
ne sais pas si les conditions seront
réunies pour participer aux primaires
un certain nombre d'hommes de femmes de
toutes façons iront voter à ces
primaires et qui peut être une influence
qui n'est pas socialiste qui peut être
effectivement de ma sensibilité
mais est-ce qu'on doit arrêter le
processus des primaires telles qu'elles
soient aujourd'hui pour les ouvrir à
d'autres d'autres partis politiques
avant que nous soyons confrontés à ce
qui s'est passé cette semaine avec l'
affaire dsk
moi je me suis exprimé à plusieurs
reprises dont une chez vos confrères de
libération dans différents papiers pour
dire quoi pour dire écoutez si les
primaires ce sont des primaires
socialo-socialistes et bien découlera à
sortira de ces primaires
quelqu'un qui vous quelques unes qui ne
sera pas représentants de la gauche mais
du parti socialiste or qu'est ce qui lie
à nouveau depuis il y à nouveau que un
sondage publié hier par exemple par vos
confrères du monde je crois
ipsos et france inter - quelques uns de
vos confrères dit montre que en gros les
rapports de force n'aurait pas trop
bougé et que le parti serait toujours en
situation de gagner
sauf que sauf que sauf que sauf que ce
kong a pas suffisamment de près c'est
que la bouche est très minoritaire et
pour qu'elle gagne la gauche au deuxième
tour parce que on a beaucoup parlé de de
la montée de madame
le pen et de est bon le danger qu'elles
ne soient pas le syndrome 2002 qu'elle
ne soit pas au 2e tour la gauche mais
mais serait telle au deuxième tour qu'il
faut encore qu'elle soit un niveau
suffisamment haut au premier tour pour
gagner
or actuellement rien dé quoi pourquoi
moi je demande ça ne demande que les
forces toutes les forces politiques
un qu'ils souhaitent participer au
gouvernement de la france
à terme avec si la gauche remporte donc
le parti socialiste mais d'autres
participent à la mise en place
maintenant d'un socle minimum de
principes de gouvernement avec y compris
des accords possibles de deux
parlementaires parce que sinon on ne va
pas sans l'autre c'est pas nous c'est
l'inversion du calendrier ça et bien et
que très vite on puisse se déterminer
comme permettant une de construire une
commune une candidature de gauche qui
rassemble au delà du parti qu'on
comprenne bien parce que oui une
candidature unique de la gauche au
premier tour une procédure commune
unique non parce que je pense que c'est
mélenchon ou d'autres ne viendront pas
sur ses positions mais au moins une
candidature commune qui met la gauche le
plus haut possible mais la finition
ben écoute et il y a des gens qui sont
directement le parti socialiste
naturellement il y a le mouvement
citoyen de jean-pierre chevènement s'est
engagé dans une dans une comment
dirais-je vega candidats candidature je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la donne change
moi aussi mes amis proposait que je
participe à cette élection
rien n'est fermé mais cela dit pour
décélérer à aujourd'hui vous pourriez
être qu on a écouté les choses ont
changé je pense qu'il faut aujourd'hui
rassembler très largement au premier
tour autour d'eux des forces de gauche
sur le socle que je vous disais si ça ne
se fait pas il ya toujours le danger que
pour se compter on participe aux
élections ce que les papes mais comme
vous le voyez je n'exclus pas mais je ne
suis pas dans la situation d'il ya huit
jours et j'appelle j'appelle tous ceux
qui veulent contribuer au premier tour à
construire une gauche une force
démocratique progressiste écologistes
forte à se rassembler y compris les
écoles
puis c'est en entendant ce que vous nous
dites c'est que avant l' affaire
dominique strauss kahn vous envisager
éventuellement une candidature robert
hue pour 2012 et que et qu'avec l'
affaire dominique strauss kahn vous
imaginez que à gauche chez les
socialistes on va s'ouvrir un petit peu
et que du coup mais pour vous le
contexte a changé les socialistes sont
d'abord avant je l'hypothèse de ma
candidature était venu mais elle était
chez moi toujours présenté comme venant
si on ne s'entendait pas avant les
primaires au premier tour le mouvement
unitaire progressiste avec avec le parti
socialiste s'il nous entendait pas moi
je souhaite une candidature commune
si on nous conduisait à l'époque c'était
même raisonnement à présenter notre
candidature il faudrait bien l'imaginer
mais mais là aujourd'hui on n'en est pas
là je pense que le parti suisse
réfléchit question qu'on a envie de vous
laver du monde d'ailleurs certains de
ses dirigeants disent il faut faire
autrement les primaires en 2012 et
encore une une question madrid vous
posez vous avez été responsable du parti
communiste pendant longtemps
aujourd'hui il semble que le parti comme
il s'efface quand même derrière la
candidature de jean luc mélenchon
devient laurent s'efface c'est un doux
euphémisme
qu'en pensez vous est ce que c'est un
bon choix dont certains c'est pas dans
le choix du tout bon moi j'ai dû tout cc
c'est clair c'est ce qui fait que je ne
suis plus dans le parti communiste je
suis je reste avec mes idées communisme
en andorre
je ne participe pas de cette stratégie
de repli jeu qu'on ne peut pas
construire à gauche dans la france
d'aujourd'hui
compte tenu que la gauche n'est pas
majoritaire en france on ne peut pas
construire une alternative
jvn alternative donc peut-être que ce
sera seulement une alternance est
regrettable mais une alternative si il
n'ya pas l'union la plus large dès le
premier tour
c'est la condition c'est la condition
donc moi je milite pour l'union la plus
large
le gars dit souvent des partis
communistes avec jean luc mélenchon sur
nous mais vous savez le parti communiste
il peut exister longtemps mais le
problème c'est qu'il est à 4 - 2 4 % et
9 % 95 et donc
celle-ci communiste a le choix
aujourd'hui de jouer cavalier seul sans
jean-luc mélenchon le parti le parti
communiste pourrait faire le choix d'une
candidature commune dès le premier tour
avec le parti socialiste
en discutant en amont les contenus
qu'est ce qui empêche jeu si on me
disait mais le parti ne veut pas du tout
discuté des contenus d'accord mais si on
peut discuter des contenus et bien à ce
moment là on peut faire une candidature
commune c'est ma position je suis un
unitaire je pense que on ne donne que
dans l'unité
le parti socialiste l'a est uni vous le
voyez bien peut-être provisoirement mais
il y a des gens qui quittent préconise
le rassemblement des partis si vous avez
vécu huchon je crois que françois
hollande également préconise un
rassemblement peut-être avant là notre
réponse le cadre est plutôt vers les
socialistes et verts jean luc mélenchon
il est il est vers la gauche
mon coeur pour que la gauche gagne et il
n'est pas dans une stratégie de repli
effectivement que je pense être celle du
front de gauche robert hue mercredi le
sénat se penchait sur les jurés
populaires
le texte a été adopté en urgence il
introduit des citoyens assesseurs ce que
l'on appelle donc des jurés populaires
lors de ses procès en correctionnel ils
seront aux côtés de trois magistrats
professionnels le but selon le
gouvernement et de repart chez la
justice du peuple le parti socialiste a
vivement réagi pendant l'examen du texte
les explications de margaux brio le
sénat a adopté le projet de loi est
adopté mais la réforme reste contestée
des jurés populaires siègeront désormais
dans les tribunaux correctionnels
aux côtés de magistrats le principe
adopté par le sénat est simple deux
citoyens assesseurs dans les tribunaux
ils seront amenés à se prononcer sur les
affaires de violence mais pas seulement
les sénateurs ont élargi leurs
compétences aux affaires d'infraction du
code de l'environnement d'usurpation
d'identité ou encore d'atteinte à la
dignité des personnes
l'objectif affiché par la majorité
réconcilier le peuple avec sa justice
les citoyens assesseurs s'est vraiment
faire en sorte que
la justice étant rendue au nom du peuple
le peuple se retrouve dans sa justice ce
projet est démagogique populiste et
inapplicable répond l'opposition qui
pendant trois jours à batailler sur le
texte et provoqué la colère d'un ancien
garde des sceaux
mais c'est une je vous le dis clairement
une aberration vous inventez d'aller
demander aux justiciables mais mme
dinovo réclame rien d'aller eux
participer à l'activité tribunaux des
citoyens qui rendent la justice pour la
gauche c'est aussi une remise en cause
des magistrats au plus haut de l'état le
président de la république est derrière
lui son gouvernement n'ont pas cessé de
mettre en cause la compétence des juges
professionnels dans dix juridictions la
réforme fera d'abord l'objet d'une
expérimentation jusqu'en 2014
le texte doit maintenant être examiné
par l'assemblée nationale
alors pour vous ce texte fait quoi c'est
une mesure populiste d'abord ce monsieur
c'est d'abord un texte électoraliste
une fois de plus on court après des
sensibilités de la droite voire de
l'extrême droite dans ce pays et c'est
le pouvoir c'est nicolas sarkozy
ce texte est populiste il est très
démagogiques à mon avis et surtout je
répète et électoralistes ccc on a une
situation là où de défiance vis-à-vis
des juges
il faut reconnaître que le problème
numéro un de la justice en france
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord les moyens de
dents dans les dents les dans les
tribunes hautes où s'entassent les
affaires n'avance pas ils n'ont pas de
moyens pour travailler
c'est ça la question et là on fait en
faire une pointe disposition
électoraliste qui est absolument sûr qui
est liberticide or ce qui concerne
également les choses pénale concernant
la l'aller les adolescents les jeunes
des enfants c'est donc voila c c'est là
aussi c'est s'aider des lois et des
projets de loi qui sont défendre des
projets de fin de règne de pré
électoraux c'est
c'est pas c'est pas très bon pour pour
la démocratie aller mercredi toujours on
assiste à l'assemblée à un bras de fer
entre le gouvernement et les députés de
la majorité
en cause la décision de retirer des
routes françaises les panneaux
avertisseurs de radars décision redoutée
des élus à moins d'un an de la
présidentielle une bronca qui n'a servi
à rien le gouvernement maintient sa
décision jérémiades une semaine
seulement après l annonce de la fin des
panneaux signalant les radars
la riposte s'organise cet après-midi des
manifestations regroupés dans plusieurs
grandes villes de france
automobilistes et motards en colère ce
n'est plus de la sécurité routière c'est
clair et net que c'est de la chasse au
pognon des manifestations organisées par
les entreprises qui commercialisent les
détecteurs de radars également menacé
d'interdiction
aujourd'hui nos clients nous disent je
ne veux plus me faire prendre à 113 km
heure au lieu de 110 je ne peux plus me
faire ça je ne peux plus me le permettre
parce que je vous le répète mon permis
de conduire également permis de travail
une incompréhension partagée et relayée
à l'assemblée nationale par de nombreux
députés ump face à leurs demandes
répétées ces élus de la majorité ont
obtenu aujourd'hui une réunion avec
claude guéant
à la sortie un ministre de l'intérieur
inflexible et des députés
désabusé ce que nous voulons ce n'est
pas du tout en pet et les automobilistes
ce n'est pas du tout réprimer ce n'est
pas du tout sanctionné mais c'est faire
en sorte que les automobilistes
respectent partout toujours les limites
de vitesse face était chaud comme comme
réunion mais ça n'aboutit à pas grand
chose
le ministre ne souhaite pas revenir sur
les mesures il veut créer une commission
mais ça va être une commission de dupes
puisque
on a commencé déjà à démonter les
panneaux qui avertit donc la présence de
radars les mesures prises la semaine
dernière par le comité interministériel
de la sécurité routière ont été prises
après la hausse de près de 20% en avril
du nombre de morts sur les routes
françaises
alors robert vous dénonciez des mesures
électoralistes pour pour les jurés
populaires à ce que là on peut pas dire
qui est le plus le gouvernement fait
preuve d'un certain courage politique
ces mesures sont idiotes et dangereuse
pourquoi idiote et dangereuse parce que
euh bon moi je suis pour qu'on fasse
attention en matière de vitesse mais il
faut reconnaître que la mise en place d'
avertissement de radars dans des zones
dangereuses parce que c'est ça le but au
départ très précis et était très
pédagogique conduisait à ralentir alors
on me dira parts après de plus belle
sauf que la réalité c'est que là il y
aura plus de limites possibles parce que
il n'y aura pas l'avertissement et je
crois que c'est ted c'était une
véritable aide à la conduite est réel
bon et c'est clair c'était c'est
difficile cette affaire je je je met
complètement de côté tous les aspects
liés à l'alcoolémie là il faut réprimer
c'est évident mais en ce qui concerne
les radars
cet idiot cet idiot pourquoi prendre
cette mesure
si ce n'est à mon avis là aussi dans des
conditions de rapidité sans réflexion
qu'est ce qu'il ya eu comme débat avec
les parlementaires les associations
avant de préconiser se disposent du
gouvernement a tout à perdre dans cette
dans cette mesure passe à fâcher les
automobilistes bien ma question est ce
que c'est quand même pas c'est là aussi
beaucoup pas à obtenir en termes
financiers un jour on parle pas beaucoup
c'est peut-être pas effectivement
l'essentiel mais quand même bien sûr les
amendes c'est quelque chose et est donc
de ce point de vue je crois que c'est
pas une démarche qui je comprends pas
bien effectivement parce que votre
contrat l'idée de
de la contradiction que vous évoquez
effectivement est légitime
je crois que je comprends pas parce que
c'est effectivement il dira d'ailleurs
c'est avec sa majorité qu'il a beaucoup
de problèmes en ce moment parce que
dangereux est de retour dans les
circonscriptions électorales
bon là les sénateurs qui sont dans
l'ordre dans leur département à la
veille des sénatoriales et ils ont des
grands électeurs du ve et de leur dire
mais vous êtes complètement con
pardonnez moi vous passez au journal
officiel
ils sont complètement le regarder et
nicolas sarkozy hier droit dans ses
bottes c'est une expression commune mais
cela dit dans cette bottine
mais il est clair que il dit je ne
céderai pas oui c'est bon c'est à la
politique aujourd'hui
oui complètement complètement et c'est
ça va pas ça ça va pas ça ne contribue
pas à la sérénité de la démocratie alors
justement parlé de nicolas sarkozy à ce
sujet mme peut-être un petit peu plus
léger dans cette semaine le film qui
retrace l'arrivée du président de la
république au pouvoir projeter sur la
croisette à cannes un film aux sorties
sorties dans toutes les salles en france
c'est la première fois qu'un film est
réalisé sur un président en exercice
voici ce qu'en pensent les
parlementaires reportage mathilde
terrier après sa femme c'est aujourd'hui
à son tour d'être sur la croisette
nicolas sarkozy ou plutôt denis
podalydès un président en exercice sur
grand écran en france
du jamais vu partir du moment où un
président se comporte comme une star du
show biz faut pas s'étonner que le
show-biz utilise la fonction
présidentielle
la conquête celle du ministre de
l'intérieur pour arriver à l'elysée de
la réélection de jacques chirac jusqu'à
2007 dans le film tout signé
sur mes plans ces liens plus que
difficile avec l'ancien président ce
avec dominique de villepin s'allonge
malacarne dominique votre amitié
une précision qui étrangement à du mal à
passer à droite
pour moi il ira là où sera sa place
c'est-à-dire dans les poubelles pour
être plus juste des milliers de photos
de vidéos de multiples témoins patrick
rotman scénariste jacques collard le
tout en évitant la fuite
on n'a pas pu déposer par exemple
scénario au cnc ou même aux préfectures
pour certaines autorisations parce qu'on
savait à ce moment là que le scénario
pourrait voyager la conquête un film non
pas sur nicolas sarkozy prétend cinéaste
mais pour remettre la politique au
centre du débat les téléfilms sur de
gaulle pompidou mitterrand ont eu
beaucoup de succès en terme d'audimat et
je pense que c'est bien ça montre que
les français s'intéressent heureusement
malgré tout ce qu'on leur dit
s'intéresse encore à la politique
un président de la république au cinéma
une première dans laquelle nicolas
sarkozy s'est peut-être fait voler la
vedette par le non pas fictif mais bien
réel ouragan médiatique dsk
robert hue vous avez vu ce film est ce
que fait réaliste il est assez réaliste
et le jeu connaît xavier durringer c'est
un de mes amis réalisa le réalisateur et
il est un enfant de ma commune je l' ai
connu tout jeune il était à l'essai par
an était médecin pour revenir sur le
film je reviens sur le feu alors bon moi
je considère que ce film révèle
parfaitement ce que sont les travers et
les dangers la fragilité de la vie
politique aujourd'hui c'est à dire les
français qui vont voir ce film diront
ils vont trouver tous les traits pas
exagéré de ce que du comportement de
nicolas sarkozy à mon point de vue et
puis vous prie vous trouvez quelque
chose ils vont découvrir que un certain
nombre de choix politiques de décisions
qui sont sont pris par des communicants
sont pris dans des conditions de vie
personnelle où se mêlent effectivement
la vie privée du président ou du futur
président
j'ai quand même d'une fiction une
fiction une fiction vous l'avez vu le
film kick et vous verrez c'est une
fiction qui est très très proche de la
réalité je crois vraiment que tout une
fiction je maintiens et je ne pense pas
que notre électorat mais je ne pense pas
que nicolas sarkozy soit maltraité dans
ce film and on est loin de la caricature
ah oui oui on est bon et c'est un film
c'est une fiction vous avez raison mais
en même temps c'est non il est pas il
n'est pas maltraités mais ce qui est
important c'est ce que ça révèle que les
gens ne voient pas dans les coulisses du
pouvoir
c'est vraiment cessé et c'est étonnant
la démocratie ce pardon c'est bon pour
la démocratie de voir ce film sortira
quelque peut-être un nom de l'élection
présidentielle écoutez une influence
trop rien je ne pense pas que ça va
changer beaucoup les choses les français
tout ce qui est décrit dans ses dans ce
film à propos de nicolas sarkozy
ces fragilités ses qualités et ses excès
ils les connaissent alors leur point de
vue et ils vont simplement trouver des
prolongements à ce qu'ils sentaient
spontanément pour finir et pour boucler
la boucle
l' affaire dominique strauss kahn
pourrait devenir un film a sûrement le
devenir pour le moment c'est une triste
réalité qu'il faut
on ne parlait que de ça va aller avec
dont il faut parler avec beaucoup de
dégâts on en est pas on en est pas en
tirer la substance cinématographique ou
ou même et à écrire tel ou tel
le phare son scénario de film moi je
crois qu'il faut là on est dans le temps
du 2 où il faut regarder les choses avec
la gravité nécessaire et on verra par la
suite ce que ce qu'en font
inéluctablement un certain nombre de
créateurs merci beaucoup merci de merci
l'amérique par le wild au havre est avec
nous et puis nous nous retrouvons nous
la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
émission même lieu même heure au revoir
michael howard